[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like Brandon Shaw if you ain't
thick please don't get involved
now Brandon six boys
what is popping happy New Year happy New
Year fam it is January 2nd
and uh
2023 is coming in hot doesn't it sound
weird to say that 2023 Jesus Christ
we're living in iRobot
it is insane it doesn't feel like a new
year does it doesn't feel like a new
year
the time off for the holidays the whole
thick boy staff had what two weeks off
damn near a year and a half or I'm sorry
year and a half you wish a week and a
half off I had some time off
time off is good time off is good it's
also a lot of work isn't it you think
you're just chilling but it's a lot dude
it is a lot
um yeah my pop was in town Papa came in
town
um I didn't get any pictures with them I
don't think I've been posting a lot
lately I've been off of uh
posting the kiddos
uh yep that's my boy Greg who passed
away I can't get too much in that
otherwise they'll start crying but yeah
my friend Greg passed away that's a
tough one and the thing is with that is
[Music]
um
Greg you can take those pictures
downtown buddy yeah
um
thing about that is
I usually just double down on work when
when stuff when you know things aren't
going I just always focus on work to
take my mind off of it
but I think this is the first kind of uh
trauma I've had in my life where I
didn't feel like working I canceled all
my sets sure as hell didn't feel like
being funny on stage
didn't feel like doing a podcast
so the time off was good in that aspect
uh that was tough and if I talk too much
about it I'll I'll you guys won't have a
show
um you guys know me I uh I don't miss
man I do not miss I feel like I have an
obligation everyone who listens to the
show not to miss so I take pride in that
so
um could I have used today off yeah
maybe I don't know am I ready to get
back to it I don't know but uh first
time ever in my life I didn't feel like
working as far as stand-up goes I cancel
all my sets so
you know something like that hits uh you
know the curveball there's no way to
really navigate I've never had that
happen before I have friends who
struggle with mental health but I've
never had one take his own life and uh
it's a weird feeling I have a lot of
anger a ton of anger to say the least
and they're just heartbroken
can't stop crying be honest with you so
that's why I probably look like this
right now for you guys but uh that was a
tough one
that was a tough one I can't get too
into it because we don't have a show
I'll start crying so uh shout out to my
boy Greg man shout out to Greg
fight wise or not a ton going on this
week
um you do have one major fight though
it's
I mean 2023 it's gonna get much bigger
than this My Boy George George squared
are fighting this Saturday
George squared are fighting this
Saturday uh the Commerce Casino that's
6-131 Telegraph Road Commerce Casino
California other an SSP Fight Night 52.
My Boy George is I'm proud of both them
keto George you guys know his story came
from Chicago was 400 plus pounds got
down to 190
um start off as a joke there he is starf
is a joke on uh
she got this dude [ __ ] you got it start
off as a joke on King of the sting and
then uh here he is man
do this thing so
I wish I was there but I'll be in uh
Vegas on tour
wish I was there to see my Boy George
I'm so proud of him so he got keto
George fighting you got tall George
fighting and uh that is this Saturday
January 7th at 5 p.m Pacific chin will
be there yep I'm gonna send the boys a
little Al Pacino Any Given Sunday
motivational speech before they go out
and fight and uh hopefully I'll be able
to you'll be able to FaceTime yourself
so you can see how they're doing for
sure dude I'm helping with the game plan
stuff like that they better win or don't
come back
so I'm proud of those boys though man
but that fight is going on Saturday
unfortunately uh Showtime or ESPN didn't
pick up the coverage which is news to me
so uh we'll post the results on the
thick boy
socials but I'm very proud of those guys
um yeah man new year new year new me you
got anyone in here set some uh
New Year's resolutions I don't really do
them
my resolution is not making resolutions
I've just yeah I've never I've never
really done them you know I just kind of
keep going
but uh
yeah I don't know first New Year's
resolutions I don't know just kind of
keep going I don't really subscribe to
that stuff those who do no shame on if
they get your ass in shape or get you to
tighten things up be more disciplined
more power to you
uh update on the fish my addiction has
gotten worse my addiction's gotten way
worse I need to post a video on my
Instagram of how bad my addiction has
gotten it started off with uh
one tank one 30 gallon tank and then it
just reignited my passion for fish since
I was a kid I used to be balls deep and
fish as a young boy I did it for my son
and then uh it just opened up Pandora's
Box into this fish world and it is
deep So currently I have three fish
tanks
I've my first fish day about 10 days ago
and I have three fish tanks of a 75
gallon tank 60 gallon tank and a 30
gallon tank
and I I have you know I'm still a one
stripe white belt and fish tanks but man
I am getting the blue belt pretty fast
the flu Vault canister filters are
second to none they're not cheap but
they definitely clean the hell out of
those fish tanks
I'm dealing with testing the waters
every day every few hours with ammonia
ammonia kills fish you got to get the
nitrogen cycle rolling so the 75 gallon
tank is up right now with no fish in it
and I'm just letting that cycle take
place before I add the new fish to it
um I haven't had any casualties as far
as fish goes I take pride in that
because when you do a tank and you
didn't do it the proper way and let this
nitrogen cycle
run its course before you add fish
you run some problems
um it's a ologist
an itch it itches I don't know how to
pronounce that
ethiologists
theologist got a few on the list do that
um
Yeah man so
I take probably another fish have died
because I've spent way too much money on
freaking fish because I like the weird
rare fish
so now I'm gonna die keep testing the
waters and I'll change what I've done
three water changes which is such a
beast but once yeah I'm just I'm gonna
think of it guys all you fish lovers out
there you know what it's like going
through with the fish tanks getting
those Cycles making sure the Nitro
nitrates and the ammonia are low for the
fish they do the water changes but once
that tank gets running once that bad
boys in cruise control it's just about
enjoying the fish and feeding them but
right now your boy is
knee deep in ammonia and fish [ __ ] and
that's what caused pneumonia did you
think about it fish are swimming in
their own toilets right with poop and
food if and they don't eat all the food
if most people over feed their fish it's
just it's just what you guys do you
overfeed the fish the fish food goes the
bottom of the tank it rots that creates
ammonia figure it out come on dude and
pneumonia is poison to fish so it's all
about that but again once you get
through the sticks of running this cycle
run the tank and that bad boy gets
rolling and you don't have to worry
about you got that healthy bacteria that
eats all the ammonia and the bad
nitrates dude you're just sitting back
sipping your coffee enjoying your
cichlids enjoying your Oscar fish
enjoying your piranhas whatever you got
in your tank
your lobsters now I did have one problem
and then I'll move on to fighting after
this
they told me not to have more than one
Lobster but I don't listen so I have two
lobsters I have one small lobster named
Bluey of another Lobster small orange
one named slice but he will get bigger
right now they're small they're very
smart they hide I was in the pet store
fish store and they had a large Red
Lobster fresh water don't be it crazy
it's a freshwater Lobster so that'd be
that slice right there that slice that
says a crayfish if I find out things in
all options crayfish I'm pissed it's
like this is basically a crayfish God
damn it God damn it oh well see Bluey
right there which one that that's him
right there see that blue lobster it's
one of this one that one I have that
exact Lobster dude
I have that exact Lobster Rick Ross text
because the I was talking about uh yeah
how crazy is that I can't believe that
just that's 20 23 free Rick Ross DM me
sorry I didn't text DM me and has this
in uh somehow fish tank some ballsy with
fish tanks and uh we post about he must
have saw it because DMV he just
installed a 700 000 fish tank
I don't know what that looks like I just
responded yeah but you have a blue
lobster with sunglasses on didn't DM
back didn't DM back I ruined that
relationship I ruined the relationship
[Music]
um
so I have those two little lobsters they
had a big lobster I named them big red
my son wanted them the lady who's just
cares so much about fish goes ah three
lobsters might get a little dicey dude
that one's big might kill the smaller
ones and what you think talk to the guy
who goes dude should be fine I've had
multiple lobsters in my tank not a big
deal I said yeah but will the cichlids
and the Oscars eat that Lobster is
you'll be fine dude that Lobster's big
has big claws you'll be fine that thing
might get the a foot long though so you
might have to switch tanks so I'll deal
with that when it grows
I buy big red the lobster my son's
favorite Lobster I'm watching them I'm
like man he's not really hiding like the
other lobsters this boy's out and about
he's he's flashing he's doing his thing
flexing all the other fish a little too
loud and then I went to bed I was like
man everyone seems to be copacetic
everyone seems to be getting along good
night fish go to bed wake up next
morning lobsters claws God
those Oscars and cichlids ripped his
goddamn claws off
so well this is horrible but he was
still had a smile on his face still
flourishing let's move into the other
tank put him in the other tank bigger
tank have more places to hide more you
know without able to defend himself
those two Bazookas are gone he's gonna
be fine put him in that tank these fish
go hold up you're telling me big red
can't pinch us no more I went nope he's
in the tank be nice to him they went say
less we're having lobster for dinner I
woke up floating tail one tail that's
the only casualty we've had
and run all this tank mess the one
casualty not my fault not due to the
water temperature now due to the ammonia
the one problem was
big red rest in peace dude we'll be
thinking about you
he was a lobster dinner for my cichlids
and the Oscars
let's take a little break for me just
chatting out fishing fighting this new
year you've got goals and factor is here
to help you achieve each and every one
of them save time and have the energy
you need to tackle everything on your
to-do list with factors ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
get factor and not only skip the trip to
the grocery store but skip the chopping
the prepping the cleaning up too factors
fresh never frozen meals are ready in
just two minutes so all you have to do
is heat and enjoy no matter what your
lifestyle Factor has meals to help you
live it to the fullest with keto calorie
smart V vegan veggie Protein Plus meals
on the menu every single week prepared
by chefs approved by dietitians each
meal has all the ingredients you need to
feel satisfied all freaking day long all
right looking to cut back on takeout you
ain't lying get Factor instead not only
is it Factor cheaper than take out the
meals are ready quicker than restaurant
delivery it takes two freaking minutes
two minutes all right get Factor enjoy
clean eating without the hassle all
right simply choose your meals enjoy
fresh flavored packed meals delivered
straight to your door again two minutes
it's easy to eat well and eat healthy
achieve and maintain your goals this
year and do I'm telling you your diet is
90 of losing weight or getting in shape
it's all about diet not how much you're
working out it's all about your diet let
Factor help you out America's number one
ready to eat meal kit and start saving
time eating well living your best year
ever had to
factor75.com shop 60 use the code shop60
schab60 you get 60 off your first box
that's code shop 60 at Factor 75
f-a-c-t-o-r-75.com job60 you get 60 off
your first box
a little break here then we'll get back
to the program kids the fans the
tradition the glory there's nothing more
thrilling than college football I love
college football all I watch is college
really and it all comes down to the
Natty the national championship is
happening Monday next Monday National
Championship TCU Georgia Georgia really
shouldn't be there because you know but
whatever my go-to for betting is my
friends at draftking Sportsbook one of
America's top rated Sportsbook apps all
right and right now new customer can bet
just five dollars on college football
there's one game left next Monday TCU
Georgia Georgia's big favorites if they
play like they did against Ohio State
they will probably lose but I think
they're going to tighten things up and
get it done but they are big favorites
man so I like bend on the dog there I
think TCU is underrated but put your
money where your mouth is kids if you're
a big horned frog fan put your money
where your mouth is all right you've got
new customers can bet five dollars on
any college football game but there's
only one left so if you bet five dollars
on an ounce championship up you get 200
in free bets instantly win or lose plus
everyone can buy multiple bets for a
bigger payout with DraftKings same game
parlays like if you are going to bet on
TCU take them and then take the over
combine them make more money make Bank
bro download the dragon Sportsbook app
right now use code shop show schab show
new customers bet again five dollars on
the national champ championship and you
get 200 in free bets instantly let's go
shop show only at DraftKings Sportsbook
minimum age eligibility restriction
Supply see show notes for details now
let's get back to the program you know
so it's part of it chin
sometimes you lose some you crack some
eggs to make an omelet
but you don't want ammonia in The
Omelette either dude
you know
it's tough guys so yeah I can't wait for
that 75 gallon tank get running up and
running I'm gonna shoot a video of all
the fish stuff how balls deep on it so
you guys can see all the tanks I have a
saltwater one coming on in March for my
birthday four tanks Deuce Bigalow what's
up can't get enough of fish right now as
you can tell I've been balls deep in the
fish I wake up my kids are running
around all I do is stare at fish cake
enough of them my favorite are the
Oscars because they're not shy I wanted
piranhas and we're thinking about
putting a tank in thick Boy Studio I
want piranhas
you guys ever seen piranhas the real shy
dude
they're boring they're they're they're
like little 14 year old Asian girls and
they hide in the in the wood I want my
fish out and about personality Oscars
have personality certain cichlids
personality
flower flower child cichlids personality
piranhas shy they hide and if you don't
feed them watch your hands
watch your hands I've been known to bite
their owners hands when you dangle the
food over they're like oh dude here's
our only chance for food boom fingers
so no promising the answers what I'm
trying to get to here I don't know if
piranhas are they're too shy for me
Oscars are not shy Oscars like having
three dogs with scales in water they see
they come up you can Pat them
all species of Prana on California's
list of restricted animals
cannot be imported or transported
without a permit
try me
you don't think I can find piranhas on
the dark web dude you don't think I'll
have a Barracuda by next Tuesday
you don't think I'm a baby great white
by next Thursday
you know they've never been a Captivate
uh putting captivity a great white
that's how gangster great whites are if
you limit them like a lion or tiger they
would rather die
how crazy is that Asians try it all the
time China they're like nah we'll figure
it out never they just keep killing
Great White like will make soup out of
it in America we've tried it just
doesn't work
that's how gangster great whites are so
one of my favorite animals I can't
emphasize enough how much I love fish
right now
and the food do have special food I have
blood worms for them I give them Frozen
blood worms nothing makes more excited
to watch them eat the blood worms the
flakes old school there's little pellets
just for cichlids of baby pellets medium
pellets adult pellets
it's fun to watch dude
then I have eels too of course I have
eels the eels they just do I call they
use the Trashmen they do all the stuff
at the bottom all the stuff at the
bottom you know the sucker fish the
plecos
gangster fish you guys probably didn't
think about that they have tough casings
on the outside so they can survive
against cichlids and Oscars
yeah they have really tough exterior and
they just stick on the glass so they
don't cause a scene dude just let them
clean the windows
don't hate on them let them clean the
windows but they move very slow so they
don't draw a lot of tension and then if
they do try to bite the back of their
skin dude they're little tanks you see
it's like that's a tank he basically has
Batman suit on right there see it look
at that yeah
Plato's get that big dude that's real
pleco is that a [ __ ] stealth bomber
jet or a pleco fish you tell me chin
another how sick looking is that yeah
they're the janitors of the tank but
they're very beneficial all that algae
but here's the here's the thing you're
probably listening it's going oh my God
I want to play go now I'm gonna go buy a
tank don't do it give that tank some
time to create algae so he has something
to eat otherwise he's gonna starve this
is fish 101.
they're cute though see a little sucker
mouth
they're a good time man for a tank
and they're tough you need tough fish if
you like aggressive fish you need tough
fish
shout out to playcos
or pleco catfish aggressive the answers
they can be
if they don't have a place to hide they
can be
that's another thing you gotta be
careful with the decoration of the tanks
too because if you give them too much
hiding places it becomes territorial
with aggressive fish they have to have
open Waters chin open they have a place
to hide they get aggressive
well I didn't know that at first I was
like why are they fighting all the time
because one was trying to you know mark
his territory this is my little tree
stump dude don't come up in here it was
basically like a prison yard for a while
whites blacks Mexicans
and also when you're fishing usually
those spots where they can hide behind a
tree or brush is where they can Ambush
their prey correct yeah so that's why
they it's kind of like instinctive for
them it's fun to watch but I felt like
Michael Vick fighting dogs for a second
and I'm like oh they told me not to mix
these aggressive fish for this reason so
that's how I ended up with three tanks
can't let him die so then my my business
manager I didn't know most people were
still on holiday I don't know I don't
know do you guys know did most people
take today off too I didn't know but I
found out later that's why because the
traffic was yeah awesome is there some
sort of warning I don't know about
observed I got to the coffee shop and I
was like you guys are open they're like
hell yeah we're open I'm like where is
everybody like well still kind of
holiday I'm like it's Monday how much
holiday do you need
I don't know how much time you did off
you spend too much time by yourself
you're just stuck with your thoughts man
which can get rough
yeah I saw they did like uh forget what
article it was it was like everybody's
New Year's resolution should be less
time on their phones and showed a cell
phone that showed why because like when
you think about if you're at like the
gas station or you're somewhere wherever
you're waiting in line at a Mark or
whatever that's usually before phones
your time to think and process stuff and
like get creative but now you're just
kind of zombie mode looking through your
phone at Twitter Instagram go through
the stories so your brain's not you're
not the creative juices or the problem
solving's not happening anymore for
people it's not good
there's a New Year's resolution I'm not
really on my phone as it is but for the
rest of you freaks out there if you're
looking for a New Year's resolution
there you go
let's get to fighting
fans like thank god dude this guy is
[ __ ] fish dude yeah if you're trying
to fish fast forward
I think yeah that show tanks
but I really have to step you know it'd
be it'd be like uh a show cribs remember
it really wasn't their crib they like
spice it up I probably need that for
tanks
like damn I know Brandon had a rare
albino Barracuda I don't they brought
that over for the show because if I just
show you my fish now compared to tanks
this is the other thing like
I should just say this about like the
fish Community I've had so many people
reach out and help me like be so cool
and be like hey man usually people when
they get into fish the first two weeks
because the tank and the the nitrogen
cycle people stop because it's a lot to
deal with just
grind out for the two weeks then you'll
be so happy oh wow that's not good let
me read that apparently it was like a it
was a huge hit but then this is why I
was let me read it hold on and so the
first two weeks of owning a fish tank if
you if you're going for like big
aggressive fish or big tanks I'm talking
70 gallons and up big tanks the people
quit in the first two weeks because of
that nitrogen cycle it's a lot and fish
die and they're like I forget this too
much but if you just power through it
pay attention for two weeks then you're
you're you're in the clear and you can
enjoy the fish
but I've had so many people reach out
with tips like right you know yeah you
messed up putting the fish in the water
not letting it run its nitrogen cycle
but this is what I did I did the same
thing a lot of fish people do that I've
had so many people in the Finish
committee Reach Out dope environment
dope culture So Dope everyone's so
helpful
the exact same thing in uh biking I
still bike all the time but remember I
got ball sleeping biking still balls
deep in it the biking can be same thing
so helpful hey do this try this change
your tire to this have you done this you
know path have you done this have you
used this app like just there's these
weird kind of I don't say weird where's
not the right uh word for it but there's
like these it's not even Niche obviously
riding bikes and you know aquariums is a
big Market but it's just within those
markets like the those cultures so
helpful they're very specific
communities yeah where they're like oh
[ __ ] like you know obviously if they
listen this for fighting or they sort of
fighting the kid or going out for comedy
or they come to my comedy show there's
nothing to talk about fish so if they
happen to listen to this their fight
fans and they're into fish then it just
like oh you need to check out this
YouTuber this thing like damn thanks
dude I had no idea because you're new to
it so it's pretty cool
gives you hope in people you know people
are cool man
uh so tanked has officially been
canceled so I'm not going on that show
Animal Planet tells TMZ after 15 15
fantastic Seasons series came along
natural and late last year God damn it
fact is ratings for the show which
follows the Las Vegas aquarium
manufacturer as they install epic custom
tanks for celebs have been tanked or
have been in the tank maybe it started
going down maybe why is there a mug shot
something about domestic abuse on
I assume they're still building tanks
so if you go down there why did tank get
canceled I mean it's the same one oh
that that is yeah I don't play careers
tank discounts after spouse Stars deal
with domestic abuse charges can't have
that
hitting fish too do we know
are they hitting the fish it is
frustrating I get I mean it is
frustrating some of them look meaty
some of my fish are like that thing
could take a few blows but you don't
want to hit Fish Man by the way catfish
are the probably the strongest fish that
ever had to hit because I want to want
to catch fish to eat when we murder them
because I don't want them to suffer when
I hit them in the heads
if they're the ones that will last the
longest hit like crazy did he can get
catfish in the tank chin I know dude
they're very usually they're like Bottom
Feeders but they're also very aggressive
they're cool yeah I like the aggressive
fish they're fun they're more fun to
watch yeah piranhas are great they're
just so big that's the thing like my
Oscars do have three babies right now
but the guy's like oh they'll get a foot
long in six months they're gonna get a
new tank I'm like good problem to have
and your attacks are freaking huge now
so you do it
I could do it I could put the three
Oscars when they're foot long in the 75
gallon tank but just them
you can't put them with other fish
unless you're looking for a straight up
prison brawl
again I enjoyed dude I feel like the
Michael Vick of fighting fishes that's
what I feel like right now you gotta be
careful combine certain fish it's so
interesting dude
yeah so interesting all right let's get
to fight again
um I mean listen it's a slow everyone
takes I guess everyone takes most the
beginning of the year off this is news
to me I don't know holidays but uh you
did the biggest thing was Bellator
versus ryzen
um they did a collab where they had the
Bellator Superstars versus the ryzen
superstars the main card a lot of people
think John Dodson was fighting on this
John Dotson was just part of the ryzen
40. so that had nothing to do with
Bellator and Rising but John Dotson did
starch hideo takoro in a minute 43
starch them looked fantastic too can't I
love John Dodson that guy was super tall
too compared to John yeah he'll look
crazy John's such a good dude love John
he looked fantastic you know the
narrative on this is belter went
undefeated went 5-0 the only suspect
fight and this guy's my boy too Juan
Archuleta his was a split decision
um you know I think if you go based off
what ryzen usually judges cards you
could see it for that so troll Kim but
in America the judges would probably
have to want Archuleta you know and if
you're that other judge who's the one
crazy judge Doug Crosby Doug Crosby
probably give it for franciscano even
though he's not fighting like wait what
30 24 or some [ __ ] that dude thought of
his mind well we can get into that I
really doubt I really I had no idea who
Doug Crosby was really delved into it
because my boy um
oh the Hat what's his name the Hat they
call him the Hat journalist
oh chuck minnaho chuck Mendenhall did a
deep dive on him what's this about Chuck
Mendenhall is this um story that he did
on that judge was years ago yeah but now
it's so relevant it's like it's news to
us now because you know Doug Crosby's
all over the news but he did the he was
literally with was with him in New York
falling for a few days dived in deep
with them they talked about on that MMA
ringer show with Ariel Chuck Mendenhall
and the British fella uh who absolutely
adore and they uh they get into it it's
so fascinating he's he's a character man
I can't believe he's still judging he's
a stunt man and that's that you know him
and Chandler close chill out an
interview with them but they're friends
so that's not exactly who you would want
interview him you'd want some
hard-hitting questions
it's like when uh the bad press or the
[ __ ] came out on liver King and he
called me to do the show I'm like I'm
not the guy I'm too nice I'm too nice
and I care about you you need someone
who doesn't really have a relationship
with you he's gonna ask you real [ __ ]
I'm not that guy when it comes to you
I'm not that guy dude so I put him on
Schultz's show I put I had him do
schulte's show you know flagrant because
a they have no relationship with them B
they only know him like everybody else
knows them off the internet so they're
gonna give him some tough love but also
support them so shelter is a perfect
show for that's a great interview too
because they make the liver King seem
human you know not just this
flash in the pan kind of you know
um Fitness Guru type of dude you know so
it's really good for him to be on there
but the point is Chuck Mendenhall
um
did a great story on Doug Crosby now
it's getting big and he did years ago
um but that was a long rant on this belt
or Rising car that he has nothing to do
with
um
uh I would say psychopath listen Maybe
sociopath I don't I don't know him well
enough you know I know he's you know he
does
you know his thing is he was a uh
he was a stunt kind of guy in Hollywood
like a stunt director guys that's how
he's met and had all these relationship
with guys
uh Ariel said he saw him at like Best
Buy and he was like do you know who I
own and I was like no this is like years
ago and Greg was like or Arrow's like no
and then Doug Crosby like wait for a
mountain parking lot like torn to him
and Ariel was like it was he was like
you know [ __ ] about fighting blah blah
yeah and here it was like I don't know
if the guy was gonna punch me or what
like what the hell is going on right now
it's so interesting
so I don't know I don't know the guy
sounds like a character he sounds very
old school he was saying like when he
chuckman Hall was talking about he was
talking about like certain fights like
in rematches he takes what happened
before and adds it to the second fight
which hey hey bro that's not how this
works
so he's like it's a body of work well no
well hey that's not how he score fights
though yeah it might be your own
narrative but that's not how this sport
Works dude so I think his his biggest
thing is his ego too you know he feels
like yeah you know he runs this kind of
almost
Suge Knight type of way of dealing with
the the judging it's very it's it's
fascinating for a judge you get this
much notoriety you know stood Crosby
attempts to explain judge in Las Vegas
MMA gyms it did not go well several say
yeah so I saw this story pop up recently
and you're talking about Douglas Crosby
but so Chris Curtis who's a middleweight
you'll see love Chris Curtis yeah Savage
great follow too for some reason uh
Douglas Crosby showed up at extreme
Couture I guess he was invited by
someone and he wanted to explain how
judging Works in MMA and then Chris
Curtis like oh cool I want to figure
this out it's like you know obviously if
you know that information you know how
to fight better right to win so
apparently every time they ask questions
the team from extreme store would ask
questions Douglas Crosby would ask
questions back
so not giving an actual answer you know
I mean so yeah see that's an ego thing
too right so but after a few minutes
Curtis realized he would not get any of
the answers he wanted the more crowds we
talked he said The more confused him and
his teammates became uh every question
the judge received he said was answered
with a question which is immediately
pissing people off of course and then
Curtis said I'm trying to get an answer
I'm trying to get an answer and not have
this philosophical Mr Miyagi effing
debate Curtis told MMA fighting at a
certain point he couldn't listen anymore
my family's uh Southern said the UFC vet
who knocked out Buckley this past
Saturday I'm super respectful right
especially when Elder's speaking I
literally walked the F out of this
conversation like this ridiculous so a
judge and dozens of high-profile MMA
fights and long time movies stuntman
Crosby an official who once referred to
himself as a judging genius this is
where the ego comes into play here you
can't have judges with egos uh in a
combative online tirade is again at the
center of controversy over a pair of
scores he delivered at Bel tour 289 UFC
282 in the former his 50 45 score on an
intern bamweight title fight was known
as the only time in database history
losing fighter had swept the scorecards
in latter he was in the majority of a
decision called one of the worst in UFC
history you know how many well this is
MMA fighting okay there you go uh this
followers in the ladders he was the
majority of a decision called one of the
worst in UFC history only by MMA
fighting uh you know as call for Patty
Pima over Jared Gordon definitely not
one of the worst in history why don't
you go look at [ __ ] the title fight
of GSP Johnny Hendricks that'd be the
worst and that thing just fell off after
a pair of events earlier this month
Krause the remaining two judges uh for
the stats sapatello fight have been
ordered to review the fight and scoring
if any of the judges are found to be
performing below the required level they
could be bent from judging according to
Micah mazuli the executive director of
Mohegan tribe athletic department
chairman of Association box commission
all right so as far as the worst call in
UFC history is I don't think it's just
based on anime finding it's based off of
like the majority of MMA media would say
that well yeah but with that so if Patty
Penman wasn't one of the most famous
guys on the planet and this was just the
undercard fight or even it was a card on
the main card this is the co-main event
because there's an injury let's say it
was
somebody not I won't list a fighter
because that's not fair to them but
let's say somebody not named Patty
pimlet it was just a random fighter
debut fighter over Jared Gordon which
you guys called history obviously not
stupid they're just doing because this
makes headlines this gets clicks
there's definitely been worse calls now
did could I see you give it to Chad
Gordon of course did you go to Patty
yeah was it a robbery probably not it's
been worse people that that went back to
what but the majority of people even me
I thought you know well actually we were
in the [ __ ] pain it was hard to tell
but
I would say the majority of people did
think that Jersey
but people that some people that I think
even Kenny Florian probably gave it for
him I forgot who it was but someone like
promised some big names yeah
yeah again it's not the worst you've
ever seen it might be a it's a tough
call but to say it was like a landslide
is INS I mean that's just being biased
because you don't like him
Cosby is part of one q a session I
stream Couture's Eric nixick
walked away with the starchase method
interview uh
uh number one outlier among the
officials during a zoom meeting a legend
the judge was combative it didn't want
to be there Liberty Ford to MMA find a
screenshot they claimed include Crosby's
camera view at one point of the meeting
which was angled up at a messing cabinet
under a faucet
yeah I think he's just you know his
ego's out of control yeah he thinks he's
you know the Dana White of judging you
know he thinks he can he's been doing so
long his name's so cemented that he can
do whatever he wants but for him to say
that he does take into account what
happened in previous fights when he's
doing a rematch is absolutely insane the
guy's a liability and this is my thing
with Doug Crosby does he have some
controversial calls 100 is he go through
the roost yes is he a sociopath probably
um
how easy is it to replace this guy
is it that tough to just kick him out we
talked to somebody not so controversial
so apparently it's really really hard to
get fired from the commission like even
if you make really fire him we can't get
I would give him a leave of absence for
some time here that'd be great for all
judges because why deal with this
controversy all the time if you're a
fighter and they're like Doug Crosby's
you know judging and she's like [ __ ]
like the fighters should have to be
worried about this one thing they
shouldn't have to worry about is the
judging but thankfully the commission
did change the rules because of this
stuff too man yeah you can't fly a
certain amount of yeah too much miles
thank you now these are trying something
though that does nothing they're trying
at least I don't know try harder
let's take a little break from me
chatting your ear off about the fight
game drama cause listen everyone has New
Year's resolutions it's a new year new
me well you need to have all the right
equipment the right supplements you need
to get your mind right you need to start
thinking like Jeff Bezos but you don't
have the IQ cool try Alpha Brain from on
it that's right the number one nootropic
in the world for my friends that own it
I like the Alpha Brain the Black Label
because it's a little more intense Alpha
Brain because I've been using Alpha
Brain for years all right think if I
wasn't using it how bad my speech would
be okay but here we are I make a living
talking thanks to Alpha Brain the number
one nootropic in the world also you can
pick it up at Walmart or you can use the
code on it.com you save 10 off Alpha
Brain the number number one nootropic on
the planet also they're so confident
you're gonna love alphabet if you don't
no return necessary you get your money
back that's right they're so confident
in uh their nootropic Alpha Brain to get
you in that low State you get your money
back no return necessary but also you
try and get in shape stay at home on an
offer so much like Fitness Gear they had
kettlebells steel Club Macy's battle
ropes get your thick ass in shape they
have streaming Fitness if you don't want
to go to the gym you want to stay at
home because you have kids or whatever
your schedule is insane they have
streaming Fitness you save temp South
all that also protein powders worry bars
you have no reason not to get in the
best shape of your life this year in
2023 it's that time it's thick boy
season go to audit.com Shop Safe temp
shop the entire website at onnit.com now
let's get back to the program
um yeah so yeah so with Bellator ryzen
you know I think it's a good thing a lot
of media didn't cover it we obviously
have the week off so we didn't cover it
um you know and with Bell Tour growing
5-0 over Rising the the the
production was great the walkouts were
great one Archer let us walk out yeah
some of the best you've ever seen very
pridish day is uh kind of Vibes to it
and a lot of people like oh I'd love to
see the UFC Bellator you know Belterra
5-0 hey
Bellator and Rising need to do this to
get traction UFC doesn't
it would be you know there's no shade on
belt or rising or any other organization
out there but that'd be like the CFL
being like oh I bet I bet we'd Crush
against the NFL guys the fl's going
maybe who's this help
we're good we're crushing it why would
we switch up our business plan to help
you out they're not going to do it so
stop with all that the UFC doesn't need
to do it Dana White had a good point and
I do believe this I think those guys
like uh horror
horagachi uh Juan Archuleta Patricio
especially AJ McKee at his age could
give a lot of UFC guys problems are they
gonna wreck shop probably not
there's only one way to find out they'd
have to sign with UFC and if you are
let's be let's just be completely
transparent here let's elf in the room
most other shows aren't going to say
this if you were that good the USC would
have signed you now there are fighters
in Bellator who came up through the
program and got to a certain point where
they should probably be in the UFC but
they're under contract to Bellator and
they can't come out of UFC that's a
different story but
if you're want to be considered the best
baddest most popular fighter on the
planet the UFC is the One-Stop shop
there's no ins ifs about it it is what
it is meant
and you'll see does all these people
going I'd love I don't get why Dana
doesn't play with Bellator and they do
this crossover because they don't need
to if I'm Bellator and I'm rising or
these other organizations keep doing
this this is different than what the UFC
does don't try to compete with UFC and
just do the exact same thing UFC does
because a you don't have the Stars B you
don't have the roster C you don't have
the depth you know so it's like all
these other organizations are constantly
trying to just mimic what the UFC is
doing Do Your Own Thing that's what made
Pride special pride in UFC can be more
opposite 15 minute rounds the Grand Prix
the walkouts the ring it was always
white it was never in America they came
here once in Las Vegas I was there not a
big deal front row but the other thing
was completely different than UFC that's
what made them special they had their
own Stars Do Your Own Thing don't be a
cookie cutter copycat of the UFC this is
completely different the fan base
especially hardcourse need to realize
all you guys going UFC would never do
this just shows they're scared no no no
why would the UFC change anything
they're making more money than ever why
would they put shine towards another
organization they have nothing to do
with beltorn Rising keep doing this one
Championship do this and Do Your Own
Thing be a different thing than just a
watered down version of the UFC because
I'd love this meltor ryzen the best of
the best fighter that's dope I don't
need the UFC in there I don't care DLC
is never going to do it so I'm not going
to put energy into it because you see
why would you I'd be like the NBA going
over to Europe being like yeah we're
gonna cross pollinate and do a broadcast
no why would they do that there you
gotta the market cornered why would they
change the business model there's no
need for it the problem with this with
Beltone Rising it wasn't put on during
American time
there's really nowhere to watch it when
it was going on live I mean we could
woke up wake up I think 4am and watch it
live but I don't think it was available
on like Showtime live was it I don't
know I don't think so
the other thing is just put it on so the
American fan base if you care about that
that it makes it more accessible so when
they're like oh the MMA media is not
giving this any shine yeah man
you know
when you're saying like the UFC versus
like these other promotions it reminds
me of the Olympics remember Olympics
with NBA like the top NBA players yeah
and they just destroyed everybody so
it's like yeah and it's the cool thing
is take shots at the big dog you know
the the big dog is the UFC yo UFC's too
afraid to do this they don't even
consider that yeah because hold up let
me switch up my entire business model so
you guys grow
and also I hate to tell you I don't
think I think he knows this but also I
don't think he cares he assumes his
Fighters are the best in the world I
don't think he gives a [ __ ] whether
Patricio Pitbull can beat one of his
guys
what's he care
well the thing about the pros and cons
pros
you're the UFC roster against the the
belter roster goes 5-0 cool cons they go
0 and 5 and then the whole narrative for
here on out until you keep doing it is
Bellator has better Fighters there's no
upside
but if you walk around the streets right
now if you're not balls deep in MMA you
walk around the streets and you say
ryzen they don't know what the hell
you're talking about you mentioned
most of the guys besides AJ McKee
knows you know who they are the only
upside is for belt turn Rising nothing
for UFC there's no upside for them
of course they're not going to do it
would I like to see it of course
but think about it if you owned a
business would you do it absolutely not
makes no sense
keep doing this makes him one
Championship that'd be great dude
it'll be phenomenal once a year do this
a big crossover your chances are Champs
it's fun it's different it's not a
watered-down version of the UFC the
walkouts are different the production is
different the Ring's different the cage
is different the announcers are
different it's dope I love it
but if you're holding your you'll be
you're gonna pass out if you're holding
your breath for the UFC do this
crossover stuff
what else you got alrighty uh there's a
grappling event that happened over the
weekend
um I saw this Theory Pro grappling six
uh and by the way Pat Berry who hasn't
like done any competing as far as Combat
Sports in like eight seven or eight
years he competed in grappling and
grappling yeah but he lost yeah of
course he did and so did his girl Rose
which is surprising Rose is a beast 65
seconds she got rear naked children by
Jillian Robertson Julian Robinson
jumped on her like a spider monkey man
God damn 65 seconds
yeah don't want to play the vid but you
can see it online somewhere yeah with
the quickness huh yep
pretty quick yeah yeah so that was
surprising that's not ideal
um
hold on one sec
oh so at the rising event Manny Pacquiao
showed up
right he was with security guards
walking through the backstage area but
apparently he signed a contract with
Verizon as well to do what boxing
but apparently he's in a box like MMA
guys so I'm not sure what's yeah I don't
know what the deal is
so so was Rising like oh we see what
Jake Paul's doing
hey Manny and Manny just did it you know
that's a bad example because Jake Paul
didn't have the same background it's
basically we see what Floyd's doing
still getting numbers hey Manny instead
of doing these weird one-off
pay-per-views finding your former
training Partners how'd you doing Rising
yeah be interesting I remember Manny
just fought that that Korean guy that
that was acting like he's like you're
the best yeah and he destroyed him of
course yeah so in an exhibition match so
I guess if you signed a contract with
ryzen hopefully it's gonna be he said
hopefully it's gonna be more than just
one yeah like trying to be the president
of the Philippines he's he's actually
part of the government
even though he's fighting as part of the
government he's a government official
yeah
interesting is the itch to still do it
yeah so he might have one more
exhibition before he does the ryzen
fight but ryzen is supposed to be in
2023 and it's boxing rules apparently
interest against an MMA fighter I'll
take it I'll watch it
alrighty some fight ooh this
announcements fights yeah your boy
Marlon Cheeto Villa and your boy of
course and Hagen they're both fighting
weiner hard February 18th Cheeto versus
Corey Santa Higgins my two boys going at
it at the Apex though which sucks I hate
to see it but also love to see it yeah
hate to see them find each other but
love to see them find each other this
one is Gang Busters our boy Cheeto
and Corey Santa Hagin signed me up this
should be on a pay-per-view though
for five rounds but yeah Apex Center
interesting yeah
great fight though phenomenal fight the
cheetah wins this one the only thing
next one was title shot yeah that's it
man
should be
great fight though
that is find the year written all over
it I'm guessing you don't want to make
picks right because you nope we'll make
you pick for that one
oh this fight yeah
might be better than Cheeto of course
Anna again Adriana's Rob font dude you
like them both too which kind of he's
gonna be tough I like them both Adrian's
my boy though yeah Adrian came to my
show in Houston such a good dude super
cool dude and he was waiting for to get
a big fight and he was hoping this fight
was gonna be in San Antonio we've had
Adrian on the show before he called in
such a good kid man stud and dude here's
the thing then I can tell you ain't
nobody sign up to fight this kid they
offered him big boys they turned it down
that's how gangster that New England
cartel crew is Rob font signed up for it
because Adrian Jana has undefeating the
UFC this dude has world champion written
all over him but uh Giannis was trying
to get it done to be in San Antonio his
hometown
but I guess Rob font needed to wait a
little longer so
that's a hell of a fight such a good
fight and is it did they say that's a
main event or no finite main event I
mean it's only three rounds I need that
to be five
not just so far it says booked for a
matchup but I don't see me in today
God he's got a uh post-fight bonus in
every single one of his fights
yeah you seeing Adrian striking it's
insane as boxing is insane yeah and
obviously Ralph wants batteries great
yeah Rob Fun's taking some beats it's
gonna be a great shot tough fight for
Rob font
and this is also a super badass Sean
Brady versus Michelle UFC this is why
I'm glad holidays are over because now
UFC's just dropping drop and fight
announcements my boy Sean Brady Michael
pierra in the works for UFC ESPN 43 in
San Antonio
I told you guys this when Sean Brady
lost his fight to Muhammad I said I feel
sorry for whoever has to fight Sean
Brady next
Michael Pierre you're up dude you're
about to get strangled
yeah that's a badass fight love that
fight
these fights are violent son just like
them freshwater aggressive cichlids
violent
uh this one else drinkers duplicates who
just really pretty much put a clinic on
uh there until well first round he did
okay well drinking two places versus
Derek Brunson for UFC I'll fight for
duplicities
very tough fight
very tough
if it's the same version that fought
didn't tell
because you saw what Derek Brunson did
there until
yeah
all right here's another this is kind of
shocking when I saw this so apparently
Bigfoot Silva who's lost 10 in a row in
MMA
um this is grappling yeah thank goodness
for that so when it first came out he
said he signed a fight with this guy
hayam gozali at Brave CF and then it
apparently turned out to be a grappling
match and
yeah he retired well the nicest guys
great career obviously what's happened
in recent
fights doesn't
illustrate how good Bigfoot Silva was in
this Heyday he was such a Savage and
also one of the nicest guys in the sport
do I hold any grudges against him for
training with him and him flying to
Brazil the next day helping no girl out
no I don't no I don't at all such a nice
guy great guy man really really good
dude one of the best guys in sport when
I saw this said big because obviously
the media did it to make it look like
he's taking an actual fight it was like
Bigfoot Silva announced his new fight
like oh so I screenshot that sent to
Rogan like Jesus Christ and Roman's like
oh thank God it's grappling I said Thank
the CT gods
yeah
and that's the main quote everybody has
a limit so he said his but his head's
the same but he said his body is just
you know obviously he's getting older so
I don't know either way
no it's not it's not gonna get smaller
uh this is interesting I didn't know
much about this fighter but he's from
the UFC it's mooc isma gulov
um he was actually a killer in the UFC
he just lost one fight against Armin
badass yeah superb oh this guy's great
yeah he's his record is uh 24-2 oh no
his Pace two against sarukin was insane
and what's wrong with him he just said
hell well he's a M1 guy yeah he's a
Russian fellow right so he just says
there's health issues so he has to just
completely retire from the sport what
kind of issues he didn't go into detail
that's such a shame yeah
damn that's a shame the pace he said oh
my God that's working was not dude he
was right there with him that if I could
have went either way
uh Ferguson for the first time ever in
seven years he's dropping the rankings
because uh you know Drew Dober uh his
really great performance
got him to that wait who did you drop a
fight again Drew Dober fought um oh
Bobby green that was a great fight
amazing fight great knockout he was able
to basically picked apart and then just
wow right hooked phenomenal so he got up
and then um for the first time ever Tony
Fergus was out of the rankings it makes
sense yeah Tony's on Harvard he didn't
give us a [ __ ] about ranking
aiming for UFC return favorite and for
your Hiatus on the way from octagon and
then I looked at her Instagram and she's
going for the 125 pound division for her
first fight back yeah I mean as long as
she takes injury free she's your next
World Champ this girl is the khabib of
female fighting she knows gonna stop her
yeah so the only thing that stops her is
her injuries if she can just get over
the injuries world champion all freaking
day all day she'll mop the floor with
people
we should get her on a food truck for
sure she's local too and for your Hiatus
so the injuries should at the very least
be better yeah hers was a really bad
neck injury but then also just the
benefit for her if you have a four-year
Hiatus and you because you know
especially in the female division it's
not as deep as the men so when she comes
back she's still the Savage so they
don't give you any warm-up fights with
the blessing for her is because she's
heavily grappling based you can get your
bearings underneath you yeah there's
gonna be some UFC Jitters but if you're
a Grappler that always tends to sway
towards the Grapplers more than if
you're a striker yeah so because she's
so dominant grappling she doesn't need
those warm-up fights toss her in there
whoever the hell you want good luck
yeah four years that's a long that's a
long time off yes yeah but it's like me
fighting again
all right so uh UFC once again I don't
know if this is UFC or ESPN who's in
charge of this Mickey Mouse chin all
right so most likely ESPN and Disney but
uh the pay-per-view cost has gone up
again from 74.99 to 79.99 god five
dollars man yeah the decision marks the
fourth pricing because you don't see
Babe Ruth since approaches struck a
broadcast deal in 2019 so basically it's
gone up every single year
they're like we're in inflation say less
increase the prices the Disneyland where
inflation cool make an average ticket
four hundred dollars
and we're still gonna buy it I mean I
haven't been to Disney since they went
the woke route
my kids are what about Disney like
forget Disney how about Knott's Berry
Farm
25.99 all you can eat not spray Farm can
be fun if you just bad not if your kid
grows up going to Disneyland dude yeah
it's like trying to get around to
Bentley all his life and you jump in a
freaking Dodge Neon
and their characters are uh Charlie
Brown yeah so it's like where's Mickey
I'm like man [ __ ] Mickey
yeah uh so this one I can't play the
video but it's basically played for me
yeah
just turn down the volume so those you
listen only it says UFC uh Patty pimlet
beats up internet troll and Jim
Challenge and by the way he was so nice
to this guy like super nice you could
see him like pulling punches not not
even hitting that hard and there was
this troll saying he can beat up Patty I
guess they were just talking smack
online
I'll mess you up so Patty flew him over
to where he's at
and even gave him money after the fight
too
and no takedowns I said look at look at
how he's soft patties yeah he's just
being toyed with him yeah
you guys all out of shape too why is he
kind of why are they in hoodies maybe in
Liverpool it's like freezing
that you went three rounds I think two
rounds and that was it and the guy had
actually decent like that kick that
question mark kick the guy is training
for sure the guy doesn't look like your
average Internet troll he definitely has
some training oh I turned his back
but he's not even hitting him that hard
because oh my god oh the guy's hands
he's like ow
the guy thought he was gonna do well I
guess so
and then Patty hugs him see you but he
says he gets his props for even showing
up
but this just shows you the nature of
Patty Pym like oh you guys want to hate
on this kid I'm telling you man not the
one to go for he's such a good person
the kids just said I probably need to go
to the hospital
batteries are super cool to him yeah
super nice and gave him money to enjoy
kindness after that guys last night
going great if he's hating on Patty
pimlic nobody's crushing life that just
hate on others
Pat's looking good too man so yeah he's
not like completely out of shape like he
normally is out of Camp yeah he listens
some of the some of the Vets told him
hey man if you want to take this serious
you can't blow up so much between fights
yeah so Daniel Cormier went on his
YouTube channel it's talking about why
usada is not testing Jon Jones as much
as they should be especially since he's
been popped
multiple times right yeah the picogram
stuff so Yuri prahashka he's been tested
I think he said 24 times in one month or
some [ __ ] like some crazy thing because
well Yuri's also been way more active
than Jon Jones true if I'm you Sarah I'm
kind of with you Sarah on this it's like
all right dude the guy's not competing
he's going to heavyweight same thing
with Connor everyone's like a little
testimore he might be doing stuff all
right but they're not they're not active
so if I'm usad it's like let's go after
the guys that are competing currently
right now these guys whatever they have
injuries or they've had all this time
off we're still going to test them but
not as much we got to take care of the
active Fighters
I'm with you other than if it was
someone that has not been popped before
I'm with you but this guy has been
popped before it sounds like you don't
want fun
I want dude by the way I want Jon Jones
to fight heavyweight that's like a dream
come true
here's my thing for all you Jon Jones
haters out there
he could the the guys he fought and beat
which is all of them except for Matt
Hamill which he did beat but illegal
downward elbow yeah that's not a lot so
it doesn't matter
just so you know how steroids work or
whatever John did that you think he
assumed that he did with the pulsating
all that
every guy he fought could be taken 10
times the amount of stuff Jon Jones took
especially back could not touch him
John if you if you're saying because of
what John popped for the pulsating stuff
and all that [ __ ] if you think that was
such an advantage you're out of your
mind
how's he dabbling stuff maybe I don't
know that pulsating stuff I don't know
enough about it sounds like maybe he
dabbling some of the dark arts there
which 99 of the guys that he fought and
beat also dabbled in look up his track
record of guys his fight history look at
how many guys have been busted and he
still were able to he was still able to
beat them so this Narrative of John's
this bad guy he's done PDS and he's the
Lance Armstrong of fighting you're just
wrong dude because you're holding that
that over John's head and then you're
fans of Leona Machida Anderson Silva
I'll keep naming guys all day long jail
sewn in you know all popped in all pop
everyone Vito Vitor Bel four popped all
these guys have popped yet they don't
get the same backlash John gets that's
how good Jon Jones is he's that [ __ ]
good at fighting it's not the steroids
so for them to take a break on them cool
man I don't get I just want to see him
fight
at the end of the day I see what you're
saying though a guy that there is some
you know questions there there's some go
well so there's some questions there two
times yep twice you know pulsation pulse
thing is gonna pulse you know he can't
just stop it one day but for I see what
you're saying Guy having that back
kind of background in PDS they should
test them more but this long layoff and
same with Connor yeah dude all right
so one of the reasons with Jon Jones was
that he was going to come back but was
going to be the most test guy in the
usada corn said on his YouTube
uh they were gonna be on him they were
going to make sure that he didn't have
picograms of any of that stuff where's
his damn test I mean why is he not the
most tested why are you testing Yuri
more than you're testing this guy was a
history of having these types of issues
that makes no sense
because he always active so I see your
point with the activeness yeah I get
that now if now if John was as active as
Yuri in the not test them that's like
the hell's going on here but with this
not active been out a hot second
but he did pop none of the Year never
pops or anything so but so anyways so we
looked at this is usada's website the
test history in 2022 he was tested four
times and Yuri is tested 24 times in one
month again you're so I mean that's so
hey you saw to chill hey after hey after
12 in a month though 20 I know 24 is
insane 20 hey back up dude that didn't
make sense that's almost every day of
the month it doesn't make any sense I
don't know it sounds like they're just
bored but it also checks the box for
them because clearly they knew you're
he's not going to test hot so to make
you like retest it so much look at this
yeah we know he's clean
all right
let's go to this real quick so Jeff
Molina who was a fighter or he is a
fighter in the UFC but he's suspended
now he's also
uh his coach is James cross
and they didn't the investigation has
not shown too much of what's going on
now but he might be part of so I have
some friends who are close to this and
they said it's we're just getting the
tip of the iceberg it goes
deep and this is his record he's a
really sad fighter yeah number 14 in the
world for a reason Savage
undefeated in the UFC
yeah but
the story's going to keep coming out it
gets deep
um do you want any more are you good
maybe one more
what's this
okay this is kind of the best one to end
on I don't know we'll see if because I
can't play the video but okay so Dylan
Dennis was on um aerial show and by the
way
I completely understand how Dylan Dallas
made this mistake so Dylan Dallas is
talking about the Raul roses Jr the 18
year old the young Phenom yeah you see
and he's looking at the the picture at
your aerial Studio who's Verna jandaroba
the girl that she made she was made fun
of by people because listen Rob
Schneider kind of whatever yeah so but
look look at this picture here so he's
talking about he goes I'll even fight
him
and that looks a lot like freaking right
it looks so much like that guy
dude hero goes yeah and he just changed
the subject yeah uh I feel bad about it
but dude they they do you can see how he
can make that mistake any of his
sunglasses on that's the other thing
it's hard to see inside you ever worn
sunglasses inside unless you're blind or
an [ __ ] you shouldn't be doing it I
mean that's hilarious by the way but
unless you're blind or [ __ ] don't
wear sunglasses inside but if you're
down Dance I'm not gonna hate on you you
know I like Dylan danis yeah um you can
see how he made that mistake yeah she's
all what the [ __ ]
so that was pretty much it that's funny
um depend on that yeah we gotta get over
to uh
find the kitchen all right okay so no
much there's not many fights going on
except for our boys
this Saturday unfortunately HBO Showtime
UFC turned down the rights to broadcast
it but my boys from thick boy Studios
the Two Georges have been training it
was only supposed to be 20 weeks but
it's been more like 40 weeks getting
ready for this fight they went from
zeros to Heroes Pros versus Joe's they
did the Ulta fight program in uh Burbank
and they uh they've truly completely
transformed themselves their confidence
is up they're in shape they have two
opponents and that is this Saturday get
tickets support my boys man it's at the
Commerce Casino 6131 Telegraph Road
Commerce Casino California it starts at
5 p.m Pacific I don't know the fight
order just get there by 5 PM Pacific you
want to see the Georgia's do work their
game plans will be made from your boy
right here talking to you right now if
they don't win they're not allowed to
come back to work so there's a lot of
pressure on the line just kidding uh but
I love them both very much they've
really earned their way here at thick
boy and they're going to show you their
hard work when it comes to fight game
Saturday night again that's a Commerce
Casino this Saturday 6131 Telegraph Road
come give my boy some support man cheer
them on especially keto George you know
what that kid has been through and this
just speaks to the magnitude of what
kind of character this kid has and he's
just such a good person both of them are
man but the other George tall George
this is brother's the starting Titan for
the time all right the kid's gonna
destroy
so show some support for big George keto
George all right
um outside that
Davis apparently still on still supposed
to fight he released his own kind of uh
response to the domestic attack stuff
apparently she was doing some stuff
there too I don't know but he is
fighting it's in Washington District of
Columbia and that is on Showtime January
7th this Saturday Javonte Davis Luis
Garcia Hector Luis Garcia uh Javonte
Davis must see TV so I'm glad he figured
it out uh but I will be in Vegas this
week first stop on the new 2023 tour
whole new hour oh he fake is coming to
Las Vegas Nevada one of my favorite
clubs in the country my favorite owner
Keith who owns Wise Guys in Salt Lake
City he owns Wise Guys in Las Vegas with
Paulie Shore and Josh Wolf will be
making a special appearance there too
doing a set with me
um not sure on what show he might be
doing all might be doing one or two of
them either way me and Josh Wolf but I
will be in Las Vegas this Thursday
Friday Saturday Las Vegas Nevada Wise
Guys tickets are damn near sold out so
get we're not adding shows so get your
tickets right now for Las Vegas Nevada
CES the technology thing fairs going on
that whole it's like the biggest
convention for all the uh smart kids out
there is going on so all you Nerds come
on out
um come get some comedy man Wise Guys
this Thursday Friday Saturday and then
Tampa Florida uh is the last tour date
in January Tampa Florida Tampa Improv
January 20th through the 21st that's two
shows Friday two shows Saturday only in
Tampa Florida also my favorite venues
and then Springfield Missouri never been
there I think that's where the Simpsons
takes place Springfield Missouri
February 3rd through the 4th
um yeah we have bigger field on there a
bunch of other tour dates go get you
some at thinkboy.com or fatkz.com that
award-winning uh sweet thick nectares
available at thick boy.com we were sold
out for the last two weeks during the
holidays we had a real uh frenzy like a
like a Feeding Frenzy of a uh with
cichlids when you put blood worms in the
tank I thought people were going after
tiger thank but they just restocked at
thinkboy.com also bourbonoutfitter.com
is our official online supplier so go to
thinkboy.com get that sweet thick nectar
and we take five dollars off all right
so there you have it man we got new
merch dropping soon as well but we have
new torments dropping I can't wait and
that's in person only but all the tour
dates will also have tiger thick out as
well so if you want to get a bottle
there try it there come get you some uh
that's it first show of the new year I
can't thank you guys enough we have a
bunch of fun stuff coming up for thick
boy same shows as usual if some big food
truck guests coming up which I'll
announce when those drop a bunch of
companions coming up some special
Companions and some other wrinkles as
well being added to thick boy the boys
here are working we can't thank you guys
enough here's to a great year for 2023
for all you listening for all you
watching this I love you guys so much
thank you for tuning in thanks for
giving us the platform and paying our
bills and giving us a job man so I love
you guys and a Happy New Year and I will
see you in Vegas this Thursday Friday
Saturday day love you guys be nice to
each other be safe see ya if you're into
thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding